right and they were jerking off like
nine guys were joking
before we came downstairs to meet you by
the way he offered me like a cow to
another man let's be real okay okay no
that's not let's let's be
that's not what happened like it's a
it's a strong accusation
let's be clear here okay
this woman right
watch your tongue fine piece of lady
yeah
smoother got her got her right this this
lady right comes back from hawaii right
and there
all the girls that went on this trip are
talking about this one guy
that they i'm not gonna say his name
that they hung out with i've met the guy
before and they all wanna they off they
all offered them i didn't offer myself a
person known to other people or just
somebody he's not a celebrity he's kind
of like he's a local boy okay did i meet
him on facebook you haven't yes you met
him gilbert oh that guy got great pecs
i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry
i'll relax
why didn't you did you see that i know i
know that was a verb everyone's very
perfect
stop burping come on look he's he's a
very handsome island thick boy that's
all i'll say and when i was in hawaii
with him you were you had a crush on him
i know he they were driving we're all
driving back to you know um yeah oahu
and i go um can i go into his car yeah
so i volunteered to go in his car
because i wanted to be in his truck with
him okay right a truck by the way he's
not getting uglier
hello so i understand the merits of it
okay um but they all got back from
hawaii and they're all they all except
for her
offered themselves to him as a party
package they were like hey will you have
sex with all of us it's not like friends
and he politely declined wow he declined
that's the moment right if you there was
a are you married no you have a
girlfriend no okay so if there was a
party package
yeah let me ask you something i'll be
honest i am i will be it's a four woman
party package yeah four women with
different women right yep right and and
they offered a party package and i have
to say
[Music]
another one
yeah well i have to know like what level
they are level i mean they're pretty
okay it's a good level it's a good level
okay right so it's four pretty good
level level okay okay
um
would you turn it down i mean i don't
think i'd turn it down i'd probably be
like listen
we all need to talk about the
expectation of this time
i'm one person i don't have a truck or
huge pecs but yeah yeah i'm gonna
kitchen sink it but
remember i might need to ride the pine
every now and then have a gatorade and
then i'll try it
well here's what we said i told the
girls because i'm the you know i was a
heidi fleiss of this trip right i was
basically like look i told him i was
like lo no expectations we'll bring some
helmets a sack of bananas oh some iv you
know some what do you call that um
liquid iv yeah yeah yeah
there will be some dents on the wall yup
we'll have a
coach with a timer in the corner yeah
there'll be pure equity in terms of how
much time everyone gets right we'll do a
clear tag in the middle right it was
there was a literally i love that i mean
you're not you're not gonna last the
round
well but i love that it's not a 12-round
fight for you but still i can get in
some blows and punches
i i like my chances to hang i like yeah
i see the commenters being like we don't
expect this out of the kit you know and
then i see it's going downhill but i see
a moment but i just feel like it was a
pay-per-view event people would be like
ah it wasn't worth it oh that's a 70
true okay i'm 100 sure there would be a
can i say this if if i was alfred yeah
it would be a there'd be a part two on
people that's absolutely there'd be a
party because what i'd actually be
hyping the sequel before the release of
the original i know but what you're not
understanding about it right i think i
am
not because i think you're done no i
think that you're like not you know i
mean you're not looking at your skill
set i am you're you're saying i only
last round but what i'm saying is that
with all the other things that you have
to offer right you probably could
recommend books yeah that will be mostly
book records
yeah yeah all right well the sex part
feels like it's a time to take a time
out let's talk books
and there'll be a whistle for that so
i'll be in the corner just a little
timer and a whistle yeah i think there's
a i yes yeah yes i think do you think
that you
like it so helmets mean condoms
helmets real me mean real health
actually oh real helmets are there
condoms out